on a de nouvelles révélations sur cette
histoire incroyable des deux québécoises
se sont fait prendre avec une grande
quantité de cocaïne en australie pour
isabelle agacé et mélina roberge tout a
basculé dans un décor de carte postale
c'est dans la baie de sydney que leur
voyage a pris fin abruptement avec une
arrestation des plus spectaculaires des
big three de la collection personnes à
bord du sea princess 95 kg de cocaïne
presque pur caché dans plusieurs valises
une valeur de plus de 60 millions de
dollars sur le marché noir australien
c'est un moment de grâce et un monde qui
donne caché secret ça apparaît qu'à
quelques stars et et julie dufresne et
luc tremblay sont partis à la recherche
des autres québécois qui étaient à bord
du navire et qui ont fait partie de
l'opération vapeur par les enfants ils
sont toujours libres comme l'air à
montréal
cette affaire était peut-être plus
importante qu'on croyait
il vous dirait la vidéo de ce dossier
est clos merci mais bienvenue à en cat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
montréal avril 2007
deux individus se présentent à une
agence de voyages et s'informe à propos
d'une croisière autour du monde ils
cherchent à acheter
si ce biais de croisière d'une valeur de
22 mille dollars chacun un mandat de
perquisition de la grc indique que le
propriétaire a accepté que les billets
soient payés comptant les policiers
décident de saisir son ordinateur son
cellulaire et le coffre-fort de l'
agence située sur côte de liesse à
montréal nous avons tenté d'obtenir les
explications du propriétaire pour la
croisière
il ya neuf familles d'hommes fusion
allait faire à du canada je ne rien dire
je n'ai rien vu de ce dossier est clos
merci mais valhubert à contrer les
paluds fait une deuxième point la
conversation n'ira pas plus loin mais
c'est quand même via son agence 132 1000
$ comptant plus tard que six québécois
peuvent embarquer sur le site princesse
selon les mandats de perquisition
montréalais et les témoignages que nous
avons entendu en australie en plus
d'isabelle agacé et de melina roberge
quatre montréalais vont monter à bord
andré tamines nicolaï kolev stéphane
chevrier
et michel chassang
andré tamines c'est celui qui a été
arrêté à sydney en même temps que les
jeunes femmes
il avait la plus grande quantité de
drogue 65 kilos de cocaïne dans trois
valises trouvait elle aussi dans sa
cabine entre étamines comme mélina
roberge et isabelle lagacé est en prison
à sydney mais les trois autres québécois
eux seraient tous revenus au canada
nous décidons de partir à la recherche
de ces trois individus mais ce ne sera
pas si simple
d'abord nicolas et collègues une piste
nous conduit chez un proche qui
visiblement c'est de quelle croisière il
s'agit on le court
il confirme qu'il s'agit bien de nicolae
kolev que nous cherchons mais il dit ne
pas savoir où il se trouve
nos recherches nous conduisent à une
deuxième adresse la personne à qui nous
parlons a eu connaissance de
l'implication de nicolas et kolev il lui
apparaît évident que le voyage lui a été
payé conseiller quelqu'un qui lui payait
hockey
une croisière selon ce que nous raconte
ce témoin nicolaï kolev aurait donc fait
plusieurs voyages avant la croisière
pour aider à mettre en place la
logistique du complot il se kg de
cocaïne à montréal va jouer aux
alentours de 50 milles en australie ça
va valoir en 200 et 300 milles de kilos
pendant ses 26 ans au service de police
de la ville de montréal mario lambert à
traiter de multiples dossiers de
stupéfiants et de prostitution parce que
même si j'ai payé un battant un voyage à
quelqu un pour cent quinze mille dollars
pour les autres ça vaut la peine
taranto la botte de 5000 d'un poche
surtout on apprend que nikolaï kolev
cherchait une femme pour monter à bord
du bateau ça nous a évité les vacances
ça va pas la tête
soit nos voeux de la drogue n'ont pas
besoin et les voyages
mais pourquoi isabelle lagacé et mélina
roberge
elles se sont retrouvé mêlé à cette
histoire alors que d'autres ont refusé
pour mieux comprendre
nous nous sommes rendus en australie
nous y avons eu accès à des documents
déposés en cour dans lesquels elle
raconte pour la première fois et sous
serment
comment elles en sont venus là nous vous
présentons dans ce reportage des
extraits des déclarations aux d'isabelle
lagacé et de melina roberge rédigé
pendant qu'elle était en détention
les voix que vous entendrez sont celles
de comédienne qui reprennent les mots
écrits par les deux jeunes femmes dans
sa déclaration officielle
isabelle l'agaci raconte qu'elle a
commencé à travailler comme serveuse
dans un bar de longueuil
quand elle prend une décision qui va
changer sa vie dans ce nouvel
environnement de travail
j'ai eu la possibilité d'emprunter de
l'argent à certaines personnes pour un
nouveau départ dans la vie sans avoir à
fournir aucune garantie par une classe
et une fille encore le quai des dettes
qui est naïve puis qui veut se faire
payer des voyages fn ps bien fait que
souvent ils vont les lieux du crime
organisé vont les approcher ont commencé
leur pays dès lors les faits sentir bien
les mettre en confiance leur montrer que
l'europe de vie que autres vivent c'est
un rythme de vie qu'ils font
[Musique]
isabelle lagaf depuis quelques années
auparavant se met en scène dans des
vidéos n'a alors pas passé criminel
selon ce qu'elles affirment
les personnes qui lui prêtent de
l'argent sont aussi mêlés à l'opération
d'importation de drogue
en australie j'ai reçu un ultimatum je
devais payer le prêt immédiatement il
menaçait - ma famille alors j'avais pas
le choix c'est aussi en fréquentant des
boîtes de nuit branchée de montréal que
mélina roberge fait une rencontre qui
changent le cours de sa vie dans les
documents elle le surnomme son sugar
daddy un homme qui serait plus âgé
qu'elle et qui la présenta des
connaissances lors de leur sortie
si j'étais intéressé je pouvais passer
du temps avec ses gaules
parfois il y avait des relations est il
parfois non parfois j'ai accepté de
l'argent mais pas toujours
à l'occasion il m'offrait des cadeaux où
il met vite et dans des bouts restaurant
pendant toute cette période là j'avais
une relation intime avec ce budget est
introduit par un ami de l'organisation
ou de quelqu'un qui pense qu'ils sont
amis ou son amoureux qu'il l'ait pas
vraiment la voir jouer à avoir à voir
jouer la game sans le savoir à voir
comment ça parle avec l'iso ils ont eu
marre un petit peu plus le m'a donné son
ami ben basât garde c'est bon c'est mon
bon de cham
il y en a qui ont amené du côté de la
production tient cook sera très dense
engrenage de possession de drogue
ils vont les renvoyer ailleurs à faire
aussi et c'est ce qui va arriver
deux mois avant la croisière le show
your daddy de mélina roberge lui en met
plein la vue en lui offrant entre autres
un voyage au maroc
tout dépend ce pays si on se fie à ces
publications facebook
elle est notamment passée ici dans ce
club près de marrakech
j'ai fait le voyage et j'ai travaillé
comme escort pendant le voyage
j'ai fait de l'argent grâce à ça un
copinage dans un autre pays matip est
plus dépendant de ton pm pouls de temps
aux proxénètes sont tous seuls sont
obligés de faire ce que les gueux leur
demande de faire elle reviendra du maroc
avec 15000 dollars en poche
c'est aussi là qu'on lui parle de la
croisière sur le site princess
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens
plusieurs étaient des amis et des
associés de judas dit et on a discuté de
la possibilité de faire de l'argent sur
une croisière en jouant un rôle dans une
opération d'importation de drogue
je leur ai dit que je t'ai pas intéressé
de retour à montréal
le shaq daddy revient à la charge il
offre la croisière et 6000 $ pour ses
dépenses
il me dit qu'un des participants s'était
décommandé à la dernière minute et il
cherche un remplaçant
j'ai demandé s'avère lien avec ce qu'on
avait discuté au maroc avec
l'importation de drogue
jodie wii remote dit que j'avais rien
d'autre à faire que d'être sur la
croisière et faire comme si j'étais en
voyage avec une amie pour le reste tout
était organisé pour que d'autres le
fassent
il m'a dit que je partagerai ma cabine
avec isabelle agacé je l'avais
rencontrée juste une ou deux fois dans
les clubs isabelle lagacé serait aussi
aller au maroc
quelques temps avant me lienhard auberge
pour vous c'est des classics les deux
scénarios sont oui c'est ce qu'on voit
le plus souvent
[Musique]
isabelle lagacé mélina roberge et quatre
autres québécois en barque sur le bateau
en angleterre le 9 juillet 2016 selon
mélina roberge
ce n'est qu'au moment du départ qu'elle
découvre qui prend part à l'opération
la croisière de rêve par de dover en
angleterre et fera escale en irlande à
sydney en nouvelle écosse à new york aux
bermudes en colombie en équateur au
pérou au chili en polynésie française et
en nouvelle zélande avant de les
conduire en principe jusqu'à sydney en
australie pendant les sept prochaines
semaines les six québécois cohabiteront
sur ce somptueux navires dans le plus
grand luxe
ils visiteront les plus belles
destinations avant que le voyage ne
tourne au cauchemar
pourquoi après la pause on vous raconte
comment la drogue a été chargés sur le
bateau
[Musique]
avec les six québécois à bord le sea
princess entreprend son périple autour
du monde
en traversant l'atlantique direction
sydney en nouvelle écosse
mélina roberge et isabelle lagacé sont
dans la cabine
p3 sandoz andré taminco michel chiasson
sont dans la c5 137 et dont la à 715
nicolaï kolev et stéphane chevrier nous
avons retrouvé ce dernier chez lui à
montréal
stéphane février refuse de nous en dire
plus à ce moment le 16 juillet le bateau
arrive en nouvelle écosse coup de
théâtre michel chiasson disparaît
selon les documents de la police il est
interrogé par l' agence des services
frontaliers du canada à la suite de son
examen
michel chiasson quitte le port de douane
et ne remonte pas à bord du sea princess
pourquoi michel chiasson est il parti
dès la deuxième escale
où est il allé il a plusieurs adresses à
montréal nous avons tenté de le
retrouver tout ce qui attend michel
richer est ce que quelqu'un le mystère
michel chiasson demeure pour l'instant
antilles
[Musique]
mais sur le site princesse même s'il a
quitté le navire ça n'empêche pas
l'opération au d'aller de l'avant
mélina roberge et isabelle lagacé
multiplie les égos portrait tant à
l'intérieur du paquebot cash chaque
escale de l'extérieur on croirait deux
meilleures amies elle découvre aussi
qu'il y à d'autres personnes à bord qui
participent à l'opération
deux gars nous ont approchés ils nous
ont dit qu'ils étaient impliqués dans
l'opération
je crois qu'ils étaient italiens
de temps en temps j'ai appelé à leur
cabine pour qu'on se rencontre pour se
faire bronzer ou pour déjeuner nouvelle
escale cette fois au pire on un arrêt
clé ici mélina roberge et isabelle
lagacé passeront deux jours à se mettre
en scène à divers endroits selon la fidh
a vite de mélina roberge
pendant ce temps andré tamines nicolas
et collègue stéphanie chevrier et les
deux italiens sont aussi occupés
soupçonne que la drogue est monté à voir
au pérou parce que les cinq gars faisait
beaucoup d'allers-retours cette journée
là bas c'est là que des réseaux pour
collaborer parce que pour problème à pau
que des québécois plus avoir des
contacts exemple au pérou pour y
récupérer des kilos de co c'est pas
n'importe qui qui va avoir des contacts
avec les cartels ou avec les
organisations criminelles dans un autre
pays
stéphane février aurait donc contribué à
faire monter la drogue à bord du sea
princess
nous l'avons retrouvée au palais de
justice de montréal en juillet dernier
après qu'il ait plaidé coupable dans une
toute autre affaire
un chef d'accusation de méfait
you came back scénique
selon nos informations l'opération a en
partie été pilotée par la pègre juive
marocaine depuis montréal tu joues avec
des enfants car si tu es capable de
transporter 1 95 kg c'est pas n'importe
qui il
la cocaïne est maintenant à bord du
bateau mais pas encore dans la chambre
des jeunes femmes selon des documents de
cour le bateau arrive dans le pacifique
sud
les jeunes femmes se font tatouer et
tapisse les médias sociaux de photos de
voyage elle passe par les plus belles
escales dont la polynésie française et
la nouvelle zélande mais elles savent
que le plaisir à cherves
quand on a quitté la nouvelle zélande
environ deux jours avant d'arriver à
sydney un dsit allait me dit de rester à
l'extérieur de la cabine pour la journée
et que quelques mettrait la drogue dans
notre cabine les documents judiciaires
australien indique que c'est isabelle
lagacé qui donne la clé de la cabine à
un homme je devais fournir ma valise un
autre passager pour clim est ce que je
comprenais être une substance illégale
toujours selon la preuve australienne
c'est isabelle lagacé qui devait sortir
du bateau avec la valise ceux qui
organisent le complot lui disent que les
chances sont minces qu'une jeune femme
de son âge soit arrêtée aux douanes elle
ne s'y rendront même pas après la pause
les révélations surprenantes de l'un des
complices qui étaient à bord de la
croisière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 28 ou 2016 6h50
le sea princess arrive à sydney et les
policiers australiens montrent tout de
suite à bord ils savent exactement où
ils vont que les douaniers rentrent à
bord du bateau s'en aillent directement
dans certaines charges
ce pont ar à 7h10 ils fouillent la
cabine paix 312 ou son mélina roberge et
isabelle lagacé ils y trouvent dans une
valise 30 kg de cocaïne
7h30
vingt minutes plus tard les policiers se
dirigent à la cabine s'est 537 occupé
par andry tamines il y trouve trois
autres valise contenant 65 kilos savait
d'avancé que ce monde leur tournée avec
[Musique]
mélina roberge et isabelle lagacé
deviennent tristement célèbre du jour au
lendemain les états unis à l'australie
en passant par l'europe leur histoire
défraie les manchettes en dhr et amine
est aussi arrêté mais nicolas et
collègue stéphanie chevrier et les deux
italiens quittent l'australie sans que
personne n'en fasse mention dans les
médias
tous ceux qui sont arrêtés plaide
coupable isabelle lagacé est condamné à
sept ans de prison
la juge n'est pas tendre à son égard à
tunis et je n'accepte pas le témoignage
de l'accusé à l'effet qu'elle n'avait
pas le choix
son rôle était centrales est essentielle
puis mélina roberge écope de huit ans
d'emprisonnement au moment du prononcé
de la peine
la juge condamne la culture de la
glorification de l'image de soi quand
les médias sociaux
elissade il est triste qu'une jeune
femme de 22 ans accepte de participer à
une opération d'importation de cocaïne
pour pouvoir afficher sur les médias
sociaux des photos glamour d'elle-même
et obtenir des mentions j'aime mélina
roberge et isabelle lagacé ne pourront
pas sortir de prison avant 2021
elles sont dans deux centres de
détention différents seul à des dizaines
de milliers de kilomètres de leur
famille la mère d'isabelle lagacé n'a
pas vu sa fille depuis plus de deux ans
et dit ne rien savoir de la faire elle
n'a pas voulu nous accorder d'entrevues
les hell avait enregistré un message
vidéo avant notre départ pour
l'australie
j'aurais aimé y aller moi aussi mais
malheureusement je peux pas je t'aime la
puce
j'y tiens tiens le coup ok nous n'avons
pas pu lui montrer ni même la rencontre
et les appareils électroniques sont
interdits au centre de détention
en rendant sa décision la juge fait une
autre révélation au sujet des valises
qui contenait la drogue lorsque la
police l'a interrogé andré tamina
déclaré que l'une des vallées sous le
lit appartenait à michel chiasson et
elle avait une étiquette de westjet au
nom de michel chiasson
mais c'est clair en faveur d'apple par
la f1 vous parlez du slip renfer
voulez-vous m'ouvrir la porte de sa
gamme après des mois de recherches nous
trouvons enfin le principal intéressé
ok a bien d'avion tiens billets de
bateau si vous alliez le pourquoi je
n'ai aucune idée que savait rapport avec
une opération d'importation drôlement
sur ce le fut france 2
sexe à la baguette
même le truc tél
visiblement nerveux il nous dit lui même
qu'il ne veut pas s'incriminer il nie
être impliqué dans l'opération et dit ne
pas connaître ni le choc daddy ni les
autres québécois sur le bateau mais du
même souffle il nous laisse entrevoir
qu'il sait beaucoup de choses entre
autres sur comment les autorités ont su
que la drogue était sur le site
princesse et qu'elle va informer vous
avez vécu
on s'aime ensemble
ce
de plein fouet
comme si le
souffle sur ces seules
m
c'est ce que
c'est pas ça
me placer
dans un appel subséquents il nous avoue
que c'est lui qui a visé les douaniers
canadiens de surveiller les jeunes
femmes en débarquant en nouvelle écosse
michel chiasson nous a dit avoir par
après été questionné par la grc
nous avons également appris au cours de
notre enquête que la grc a rencontré
nicolas et kolev nicolaï kolev nous a
fait savoir qu'il voulait être payé pour
raconter son histoire
nous avons refusé quant au fameux choc
daddy les policiers savent qui il est
selon l'avocat de mélina roberge
la grc ne l'identifient pas publiquement
mais nous savons qu'elle a interrogé
l'entourage de mélina roberge et
d'isabelle agacé à propos d'un homme qui
s'appelle henry sous sans doute n'en
était pas du tout l'image que j'aimerais
non plus que qu'on me donne pour qu'il
faut que j'aie jamais fait
je connais les défis personnellement
toujours été comme une petite heure il a
aussi utilisé isabelle lagacé comme
administratrice dans une compagnie
il correspond exactement à la
description faite par mélina roberge en
cours sur les réseaux sociaux
il se présente comme un oiseau de nuit
qui fait aussi des affaires en ligne
il vend des montres et en a offert à
mélina roberge
nous l'avons filmé à montréal en juin
dernier il était accompagné d'une autre
jeune femme
il nie catégoriquement avoir été
impliqués dans l'opération
je suis pas du tout cet appel à vous
correspondez en tout point à la
description qu'elle a fait
oui je comprends pas je comprends un peu
sur le côté continental mes fans
admettez moi pourquoi les autres
québécois qui étaient sur la croisière
ne sont ils pas inquiété par la justice
la grc refusent de commenter toute
enquête ou procès en cours si une de ces
filles là arrêt 10e journée loeb il ya
pas justement il lui aussi a été
chercher c'est certain je vois le monde
relié à ces deux organisations le
paleron peau qui vont rester tranquilles
ils vont comprendre leurs peines qui ont
un parent leur sentence
pizarro fédéral
les proches et les familles de mélina
roberge et d'isabelle lagacé craignent
justement les représailles de secours
toujours en australie
la mère de minina roberge a dit au juge
que sa fille aurait voulu collaborer
plus mais pas au prix de mettre sa
famille à risque surtout que ce que
michel chiasson laisse entendre c'est
que l'arrestation des québécoises aussi
spectaculaire soit elles ne seraient
peut-être que la pointe de l'iceberg
vous cache pas que je suis une pause
quartiers qui étaient interceptées par
les douaniers ce qu'on s'est passé hier
ce cas nadeau qui a pensé puis combien y
en a qui ont passé de dévier l'attention
puis de faire premier quelqu'un ça s'est
toujours vu dans des organisations dans
nos échanges
michel chiasson laisse tomber cette
phrase qui pourrait nous laisser croire
que c'est ce qui se serait passé que les
deux jeunes femmes auraient pu servir
d'appât
uglar
que valait m'appelait michel chiasson
nous quittera sans nous en dire plus à
ce sujet laissant planer le mystère
le sea princess a repris la mer mais on
n'a vraisemblablement pas fini
d'apprendre tout ce qui s'est passé à
son bord à l'été 2016
au nom de toute l'équipe on espère que
vous avez apprécié les enquêtes de ce
soir on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]